it's molar time I've been Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show that right there
is the shortest intro you will ever hear
to the Ben Shapiro show but we got so
much to cover because only one person in
America apparently has read all 400
pages of the Mallo report he's sitting
right here you're listening to the sound
of his voice right at this moment we're
gonna go through as much of this as
humanly possible over the course of the
next hour you're going to know much more
than you did when you first started I
will give you my conclusions I will give
you the analysis I'll give you the text
everything you could possibly want but
first admit it you think that cybercrime
is something that happens to other
people you might think nobody wants your
data or that hackers can't grab your
passwords or credit card details you
would be wrong stealing data from
unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi it's
one of the simplest and cheapest ways
for hackers to make money when you leave
your internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your passwords
and credit card numbers on a giant
billboard for the rest of the world to
see
that's why I decided to take action to
protect myself from cyber criminals I
use Express VPN expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address expressvpn has
easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly in
the background of your computer phone
and tablet turning on expressvpn
protection that only takes one click
using expressvpn I can safely surf on
public Wi-Fi without being snooped on or
having my personal data stolen for less
than seven bucks a month you can get the
same expressvpn protection that I have
expressvpn is rated the number one VPN
service by TechRadar it comes with a 30
day money back guarantee so go protect
your online activity today find out how
you can get three months for free at
expressvpn comm slash Penn that's expr
ESS VPN comm slash been for three months
free with a one-year package visit
expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn more
go check it out right now okay so the
Mullen report is out and we will get to
all of the contents of that in just one
second I will break the entire thing
down for you as best I can inside of one
hour it's going to be magnificent but we
have to start with the Attorney General
of the United States who held a really
random press conference at the beginning
of the day now this is a weird thing to
do the reason that it's a weird thing to
do is because we already have Attorney
General bars letter which is his
summation of his findings regarding the
bottom line of the Muller report I think
the reason that he actually held the the
press con
prince was to push two particular points
one point was that he was being as
transparent as humanly possible and the
second point was that he was using
president Trump's emotional state as his
basis for adjudicating whether or not
the president was guilty of obstruction
of justice those were I think the two
key takeaways so obviously he's already
said that the Trump campaign did not
collude he's already said that this is
that he's reacting as little as humanly
possible
he was also pointing out I think that
the President had already seen the
report but that that was not illegal
that's clip five him talking about the
President's Council being given the
opportunity to read the report before
release
in addition earlier this week the
president's personal counsel requested
and was given the opportunity to read a
final version of the redacted report
before it was publicly released that
request was consistent with the practice
followed under the ethics and Government
Act which permitted individuals named in
a report prepared by an independent
counsel the opportunity to read the
report before publication the
president's personal lawyers were not
permitted to make and did not request
any ridak okay so that was bars taken I
think that's important him saying that
the president is not here to hide the
information that's in the report and it
is obvious by the way that the president
could have asserted executive privilege
at any point in the middle of this
report as we'll see there's plenty of
information in the report that
definitely falls under the rubric of
executive privilege if the President of
the United States wanted to assert it so
Barr is pointing out that the president
was not really hiding a lot which is
true also Barr points out that we have
to bear in mind the context of Trump's
actions particularly with regard to
obstruction of justice now the report
breaks down the Mulla report breaks down
into two sections section one is about
Trump Russia collusion as I suggested
before I didn't think there was going to
be a lot of enormous new information
about Trump Russia collusion and there
really isn't it really is a rehash of
stuff we already knew the most important
stuff being that June 2016 Trump Tower
meeting between Donald Trump jr.
and Natalia vessel Mets Keio who is a
lawyer who is acting as sort of a
Russian front - supposedly pass
information about Hillary Clinton to the
Trump campaign they're also bunch of
Roger stone references but
not a lot of revelations in the first
half of the report the stuff that was
revelatory I think to everybody was the
stuff in the second half of the report
the obstruction of justice stuff and
there the question becomes did the
president's obstruct justice when he
repeatedly sounds it off about wanting
to get rid of Jeff Sessions or when he
repeatedly sounded off about wanting to
fire Robert Muller or when he repeatedly
reached out to members of his team and
and sort of patted them on the back when
they did things that he wanted and then
offered them the stick when they did not
now
the standard of obstruction of justice
as laid out in the actual Mullah report
is under 28 CFR 600 point for a federal
crimes committed in the course of and
with intent to interfere with the
special counsels investigation such as
perjury obstruction of justice the
destruction of evidence and intimidation
of witnesses so they break down several
basic elements of the crime in this
Muller report and some of the elements
of the crime include intent to commit
obstruction of justice so according to
the Mellow report itself obstruction of
justice law reaches all corrupt conduct
capable of producing an effect that
prevents justice from being duly
administered regardless of the means
employed an effort to influence a
proceeding can qualify as an endeavor to
obstruct justice even if the effort was
subtle or circuitous and however
cleverly or with whatever cloaking of
purpose it was made an improper motive
can render an actor's conduct criminal
even when the conduct would otherwise be
lawful and within the actor's authority
so if President Trump was trying to
assert some sort of obstruction against
he was trying to get people in his team
to corruptly impact the malla report
then this would serve as obstruction of
justice according to this interpretation
of the law but you do have to have
intent you do have to have intent so
there has to be a nexus with a current
investigation and this is where things
get dicey there has to be a nexus with
the Muller investigation so in other
words if Trump just decided I'm firing
Robert Muller because I don't like the
way his tie looks today
that's not obstruction of justice if
Trump fires Robert Muller because he
wants to obstruct the investigation
that's obstruction of justice maybe
although he still has the authority to
fire
Robert Muller for any reasons probably
more impeachable than even obstruction
of justice according to the Muller
report there must be a nexus with in a
current investigation that Nexus showing
has both subjective and
objective components as an objective
matter a defendant must act in a manner
that is likely to obstruct justice such
that the statute excludes defendants who
have an evil purpose but use means that
would only unnaturally and improbably be
successful in other words you have to be
effective in your attempts to obstruct
justice or at least the attempt must be
somehow within the boundaries of reason
as a subjective matter the actor must
have contemplated a particular
foreseeable proceeding in other words
again Trump must have intent
it must have wanted to shut down the
Muller report because he thought that
its result would be bad for him it can't
just be that he wants to shut down the
Muller report because he thinks that the
Muller report is just a waste of
government money for example that's why
there is the element of corruptly in the
obstruction of justice law the word
corruptly provides the intent element
for obstruction of justice
it means acting knowingly and
dishonestly or with an improper motive
the requisite showing is made when a
person acted with an intent to obtain an
improper advantage for himself or
someone else inconsistent with official
duty and the rights of others that last
phrase is the one that matters
inconsistent with official duty and the
rights of others as we will see
President Trump
continually tried to interfere with
players surrounding the Muller
investigation without in any underlying
way forcing people to lie and he did so
not because he wanted in my opinion and
in the opinion of Attorney General Barr
not because he wanted to shut down or
obstruct the Muller investigation but
because he found the entire thing
embarrassing and he was attempting to
avoid press embarrassment for the most
part the most damaging section of the
obstruction statute is witnessed
tampering a more specific provision in
section of 1512 according to the Muller
report prohibits tampering with a
witness that would make it a crime to
knowingly use intimidation or corruptly
persuade another person or engage in
misleading conduct toward another person
with intent to influence delay or
prevent the testimony of any person in
an official proceeding to hinder delay
or prevent the communication to a law
enforcement officer as we will see
there's behavior that verges on this but
doesn't actually cross over into that
boundary and finally there's the
question of the attempt is there attempt
at obstruction of justice Muller says
yes he says that the section includes
attempt so if you try to obstruct
justice but you fail then that could
theoretically be obstruction of justice
now the reason that he lays out this
interpretation of the law is because
Trump's activity
could legitimately be interpreted in a
couple of different ways on the one hand
it could be interpreted as President
Trump trying to actively obstruct the
Moller investigation because he didn't
want criminal activity to be uncovered
by the Muller investigation possibility
number two is that Trump is a very
frustrated guy who spends a lot of time
doing immoral bad things and then does
more immoral bad but non criminal things
in order to cover up the original things
that he did so looks sort of like the
stormy Daniel scandal in other words
strips a pornstar it's embarrassing and
immoral it is not criminal and then he
does something even more embarrassing
and immoral but not criminal
he then pays her off to keep her silent
just before an election this is the
pattern for Trump so you can interpret
his activities in one of two ways
Attorney General bar I think properly
interprets Trump's activities in the
second way that I named and he
especially does that in light of the
fact that if he had attempted to
prosecute Trump under obstruction of
justice he would have to prove his case
beyond a reasonable doubt that would not
have happened here whether you're on the
left or the right
you can think the President did
something criminal there is no
prosecutor who would have taken up this
case here's a difference between the
Hillary Clinton case and the Donald
Trump case in the Hillary Clinton case
intent was not an element of the crime
if you expose classified information to
public scrutiny by creating a server and
put in classified documents on it that
is in and of itself a crime there's no
intent necessary that's why it was
ridiculous when James Comey than the
head of the FBI said that Hillary had
not committed a criminal act because she
lacked the requisite intent there is no
requisite intent it's a strict liability
crime there is no requisite intent in
that section of the law there is
requisite intent when it comes to
obstruction of justice
so the reason I'm laying all this forth
is because that's where attorney general
Barr is going when he says that the
president and the president emotion
matter he says the reason he invoked
that is because that stuff is in the
report because it is relevant to
determining whether he had the requisite
intent to commit obstruction of justice
in his emotions so what did you say to
people on both sides of the aisle we're
concerned that you were trying to
protect the president
actually the statements about his is his
sincere beliefs are recognized in the
report that there was substantial
evidence for that so I'm not sure what
your basis is for saying that I am being
generous to the president okay so he so
people are treating bar as though bar is
a deeply partisan figure here now
there's a case to be made that bar is
partisan insofar as he works for the
President of the United States but I
don't see how an objective prosecutor
could bring an obstruction of justice
case or a or a collusion case on the
basis of the evidence that's actually in
the Mullen report so in a second we're
gonna get to all of that we'll also show
you that the media were attempting to
preemptively spin this report even
before it was out again I think it was a
mistake to hold this press conference in
the first place but I think the reasons
that I laid forth are the reasons that
Bart did it one he wanted to show that
he was transparent and Trump was
transparent and - he wanted to point out
that obstruction of justice is an intent
crime okay we'll get to more of this in
just one second first you've heard me
talk about how ring is reinventing home
security with doorbells cameras even an
alarm you can install yourself now
they've reinvented the neighborhood
watch with a new app that created called
neighbors buy a ring you remember the
neighborhood watch it's been around for
a while I remember it from growing up
it's still a big thing people care about
making their neighborhood safer I know I
do so ring a company synonymous with
reinventing home security reinvented the
neighborhood watch
the neighbors half is like a new
neighborhood watch on your phone people
taking stuff off porches trying
doorknobs late at night missing dogs the
neighbors absence real-time
notifications to your phone whenever one
of your neighbors posts a heads-up about
something that's going on which keeps
you informed and allows you to keep
yourself safer the neighbors hat by ring
is completely free anyone can join even
if they don't own a ring device so I
downloaded it myself from the app store
I put in my address I set the area
around my home for two miles cuz I
really only want to know what's going on
within two miles it's hyperlocal like
that that's it it's easy and sure enough
there's a guy who is siphoning like
natural gas from somebody's house is
wild you got to check out the neighbors
app yourself the easiest way to get it
going is ring calm /up hero make your
neighborhood safer today with the
neighbors hat by ring at ring calm /sh
appear oh so as they say Attorney
General bar does this presentation and
the media naturally have to set their
side which is that bar is a political
part
again even though the president of the
united states did not assert executive
privilege even though the redactions are
minimal I've looked at the report they
really only apply in the Roger stone
investigation which is ongoing the media
is still were claiming that this was
some sort of cover-up by attorney
general bar which I failed to see how
it's a cover-up when I can read the
document and you can read the document
and everybody can read the documents
still you saw all the legal analysts
saying ridiculous silly things Neal
Katyal his legal analyst over on CNN he
suggested or MSNBC rather he suggested
that Barr sounded like a spokesperson
rather than the Attorney General yeah I
mean I agree with you the rhetoric here
was extraordinary it sounded like a
spokesman not an attorney general and
the word collusion I mean a lawyer
doesn't use that term because there is
no crime of collusion only Trump uses
that term and so you have the Attorney
General parroting that but to me there
was one bigger thing that I saw which
was what Barr didn't tell us we know
there's one sentence in the Muller
report which says do not this does not
exonerate Trump did we hear a word of
that in bars whatever 15 10 minute
summary there's nothing I heard about
that
okay well then that is very silly when
he says that that bar using the word
collusion is some sort of manipulation
um everyone in the media has been using
the word collusion to describe this for
two odd years let's not pretend that
that bar invented the word collusion it
really is an absurdity now with all of
that said the case can be made that Barr
was coming out to preemptively spin this
thing in favor of his own take on the
issue as I say maybe that's true maybe
that's not but the model report was
revealed like an hour and a half later
and it says exactly what it says so
let's get to the actual Muller report
here we go guys it's a it's an
exploration let's have a party so the
the MOA report starts off with about a
hundred and ninety pages 220 pages
something like that on the Trump Russia
collusion stuff and the effective
findings are that Trump Russia collusion
did not occur that members of the Trump
campaign were giving shoutouts to
WikiLeaks that there were certain
members of the Trump campaign who are
unwittingly acting as kind of near pawns
of the Russians Carter Page George
papadopolis for example but that there
was no high-level collusion between the
Trump campaign and Russia
and there really isn't that much more
that we didn't know in the Trump Russia
collusion part now I will say this the
information that is clear there there
are two conclusions that are pretty
obvious and should be stated right at
the outside here one is that with the
number of Trump Russia contacts that
were happening during the election for
all the talk about how this
investigation the Trump Russia
investigation was begun under corrupt
auspices I don't see the evidence of
that I see evidence that the Trump
Russia investigation became more corrupt
as time went on
particularly with them using the steel
dossier which turns out to be a bunch of
crap the steel dossier is only mentioned
in this document a couple of times and
that is because the Muller report found
virtually nothing that corroborated any
section of the steel dossier so the fact
that the FBI was using the steel dossier
as the basis for large swathes of the
investigation including a FISA warrant
against Carter Page is just an absurdity
on its face that does not mean as I have
said all along that the investigation
was initiated under improper auspices it
means that it became improper over time
if anything it also doesn't look like
Muller is a political partisan hacker
who's simply attempting to juvinity rias
work of effusion gps or something like
that so that is that is a conclusion
that is worthwhile noting here the
second conclusion that is worthwhile
noting is that again there is nothing in
the actual report that suggests that
President Trump had any deep abiding
deal going with the Russian government
basically as with all things Trump as I
have said again and again Trump does
something embarrassing and then he
doesn't want to be embarrassed so he
does something else embarrassing that is
the nature of the Trump Russian
collusion stuff okay so let's jump in so
the report begins by talking about the
social media campaign in the GRU which
is the new fangled KGB of Russia hacking
operations they say that those coincided
with a series of contacts between Trump
campaign officials and individuals with
ties to the Russian government the
office investigated whether those
contacts reflected or resulted in the
campaign conspiring or coordinating with
Russia in its election interference
activities although the investigation
established that the Russian government
perceived it would benefit from a trump
presidency and worked to secure that
outcome and that the campaign expected
it would benefit electoral II from
information stolen and released through
Russian efforts the investigation did
not establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired or coordinated with
the Russian government in its election
interference activities in other word
Trump was happy that WikiLeaks was doing
what it was doing Trump was perfectly
happy that the Russian government seemed
to hate Hillary Clinton but that was
about it that's the bottom line takeaway
and again I'm reading directly from the
the Muller report mellow report also
says while the investigation identified
numerous links between individuals with
ties to the Russian government and
individuals associated with the Trump
campaign the evidence was not sufficient
to support criminal charges now that is
not to say that not that no criminal
behavior happened may be criminal
behavior happened but there was not
enough evidence to support criminal
charges among other things the evidence
was not sufficient to charge any
campaign officials as an unregistered
agent of the Russian government or other
Russian principle our evidence about the
June 9th 2016 meeting and WikiLeaks
releases of hacked materials was not
sufficient to charge a criminal campaign
finance violation further the evidence
was not sufficient to charge that any
member of the Trump campaign conspired
with representatives of the Russian
government to interfere in the 2016
election so notice that language was not
sufficient to charge not sufficient to
charge over and over not sufficient to
charge that suggests that Muller still
suspects that something nefarious might
have been going on but there is no
evidence to actually fulfill that
expectation and I think that when you
read the report there's fairly good good
feeling that the Trump campaign was
happy about all this stuff but again
there is no evidence to support the idea
that they were actively involved with
Russian collusion or conspiracy under
any criminal statute
so the Muller report talks about a
variety of matters that investigated
they say for example the investigation
established the interactions between
russian ambassador sergei kiss lyac and
from campaign officials both of the
candidates April 2016 foreign policy
speech in Washington DC and during the
week of the RNC were brief public and
non-substantive you remember these were
treated as bombshells the fact that
Sergei Kinsley AK met with people during
RNC week this was treated as a bombshell
by the New York Times the investigation
did not establish that one campaign
officials efforts to dilute a portion of
the Republican Party platform on
providing assistance to Ukraine were
undertaken at the behest of candidate
Trump or Russia so in other words there
was one campaign official who wanted to
have better relations with the Russians
and the campaign platform was changed on
Ukraine to reflect that but that was not
a reflection of Trump
imposing that from above or Russia
seeking it the investigation also did
not establish that a meeting between
Sergei kis lyac and Jeff Sessions in
September 2016 at sessions Senate office
included any more than a passing mention
of the presidential campaign now you'll
recall that that meeting was the basis
of session recusing himself from the
Muller investigation well from the Trump
Russia investigation because before
Muller from the Trump Russia
investigation in the first place
according to the Mellow report the
office learned that some of the
individuals we interviewed or whose
conduct we investigated including some
associated with the Trump campaign
deleted relevant communications or
communicated during the relevant period
using applications that feature
encryption or to the or that do not
provide for long term retention of data
or communications records in such cases
the office was not able to fully
corroborate witness statements through
comparison to contemporaneous
communications or fully question
witnesses about statements that appeared
inconsistent with other known facts
accordingly says the Muller report while
this report embodies factual and legal
determinations that the office believes
to be accurate and complete to the
greatest extent possible given these
identified gaps the office cannot rule
out the possibility that the unavailable
information would shed additional light
or cast in a new light the events
described in the report in other words
there are holes in the evidentiary
record here and that's not particularly
shocking people in public life use
encrypted communications
all the time I use encrypted
communications all the time because I
don't like being hacked
so that doesn't necessarily mean
corruption it does mean that there are
holes in the evidentiary record and then
the lamella report goes through all of
these supposed connections between the
Trump campaign and Russia and most of it
as I say is about the Trump campaign
being very excited that Russia is is
stumping in its favor but no actual
collusion no actual collusion it's when
we get to the obstruction that things
get truly interesting and so I'm going
to fast-forward to the obstruction in
just one second I think that's where the
important stuff in the report lies as I
suggested it would before the report
even came out cuz I'm just great that
way we'll get to that in just one second
first we the people holsters offers
custom-made holsters all produced in the
United States of America they designed
their own holsters in-house that means
they don't use any third party molds for
their holsters instead they design every
unique mold in Las Vegas in order to
best fit each and every firearm
perfectly they constantly update designs
adding new designs every month that lets
them stay up to date on the newest
models that come out
We the People holsters even have their
own 3d design team who measures every
micro millimeter of their guns to ensure
the perfect fit they're really awesome
I've got one myself they're unique an
intuitive clip design allows for you to
easily adjust both the cans and the
right of your holster so that will fit
comfortably and securely at all times
every holster also has an adjustable
retention which is signaled with a click
sound now once you know that that that
firearm is securely in place if you ever
want more attention you tighten one
screw you're done custom printed designs
in-house thin blue line thin red line
Constitution camo American flag more
coming out each month and we the people
holsters they start at just 37 bucks
apiece which is a great price for a
holster that comes with a lifetime
guarantee every holster ships free it is
not a perfect fit send it back for a
refund right now listeners in the ben
shapiro show can go to we the people
holsters comm slash ben and her promo
code bennett check out to get $10 off
your first holster that is as low as 37
bucks shipping is free with an
additional ten bucks off using my promo
code again that's We the People holsters
dot-com slash Ben promo code Ben at
checkout for ten bucks off go check them
out right now great American company and
they make amazing product ok so as I say
the mullah report has to haves half
number-one about Trump Russia collusion
not much there that we didn't already
know just a lot of talk about George
papadopolis and his weird relationship
with an him Joseph Smith Sid who was
maybe a Russian front and Carter Paige
who's a weirdo who kept traveling to
Moscow but he would file his reports up
the chain and nobody seems to take
advantage of those reports or care about
his reports so there's not a lot on the
Trump Russia collusion front that we
didn't already know but as I say the
investigation I don't think from this
report was begun under evil auspices
although we will find that out when the
Inspector General of the DOJ Michael
Horowitz releases his own report on
Trump Russia now we get to the heart of
the report the heart of the report is
the stuff on obstruction of justice so
the stuff on obstruction of justice is
the most dangerous for President Trump
now I will leading up to this attorney
general Barr said listen if there's no
underlying collusion there's nothing to
obstruct that is true it is also true
that if you order people to lie to the
government that still constitutes
obstruction of justice so that is sort
of where the controversy lies did Trump
order anyone to lie or did he just sort
of imply that he would like people to
lie to the press was he telling people
to lie to the government was he trying
to shut down the Muller investigation to
avoid some sort of criminal criminal
charge
or is he doing or was he just saying
stuff because he was angry you know my
solution for all of this for President
Trump is the dude says a lot of stuff
cuz he's angry and he's angry in large
part because he feels like his election
victory is being taken away from him by
a media that was determined to suggest
that he did not in fact win the election
on his own merits but only because of
Russian interference in any case the
Mellow report says first a traditional
prosecution or declination decision
entails a binary determination to
initiate or decline a prosecution but we
determined not to make a traditional
prosecutorial judgement remember the
mullah report did not recommend that
Trump be prosecuted or not prosecuted
instead they just presented the evidence
to bar and bar the Attorney General said
I'm not going to prosecute the office of
legal counsel has issued an opinion
finding that the indictment or criminal
prosecution of a sitting president would
impermissible II under mine the capacity
of the executive branch to perform its
constitutionally assigned functions they
disagree they say a federal criminal
again accusation against a sitting
president would place burdens on the
president's capacity to govern but in
their later analysis they say well we
would still not allow that to prevents
us from recommending a prosecution they
say well the OLC opinion concludes a
sitting president may not be prosecuted
it recognizes that a criminal
investigation during the president's
term is permissible the OLC opinion also
recognizes that the President does not
have immunity after he leaves office and
if individuals other than the president
committed an obstruction offense they
may be prosecuted at this time and then
they say we considered whether to
evaluate the conduct we investigated
under the justice manual standards
governing prosecution and declination
decisions we determined not to apply an
approach that could potentially result
in a judgement that the president
committed crimes so in other words maybe
he committed crime maybe he didn't but
we're not willing to go there
that's basically what Muller found they
said if we had confidence after a
thorough investigation of the facts that
the president clearly did not commit
obstruction of justice we would so state
based on the facts and the applicable
legal standards we are unable to reach
that judgment in other words this is a
judgment call this is a this is a
question as to whether the president was
safe at home or whether he was out at
home and we are not going to play on we
are instead gonna leave that up to the
Attorney General and what Barr says is
that there is not evidence sufficient to
establish a prosecute prosecution for
obstruction of justice which after
reading the report I think is probably
the the fair way to come down on this
okay then we get into the actual meat of
the matter so the report suggests during
the 2016 presidential campaign questions
arose about the Russian government's
apparent support for candidate Trump
after WikiLeaks released politically
damaging democratic party emails that
were reported to have been hacked by
Russia Trump publicly expressed
criticism that Russia was responsible
for the hacks Trump also denied having
any business in or connections to Russia
even those latest 2016 the Trump
Organization was in fact pursuing the
Trump Tower in Moscow after the election
the president expressed concerns to
advisers that reports of Russia's
election interference might lead the
public to question the legitimacy of his
election okay none of that is
obstruction of justice that's all public
facing Trump being embarrassed the
report says that there was conduct
involving FBI director Comey and Michael
Flynn and talked about how in mid
January 2017 Michael Flynn the national
security adviser falsely denied to the
vice president other administration
officials and FBI agents that he had
talked to Russian ambassador Sergei kis
lyac and then the day after the
president requested Flynn's resignation
the president told an outside adviser
now that we fired Flynn the Russia thing
is over
that is not obstruction of justice he
did not tell Flynn to lie to the FBI
later that afternoon the president
cleared the Oval Office we know this
already from what James Comey has said
and then asked if Comey could see his
way clear to letting this go but he did
not actually do anything about that he
didn't fire call me when Comey decided
not to let the thing go so that's really
not obstruction of justice either saying
a thing is not obstruction and then they
talk in the report about the president's
reaction to the continuing Russia
investigation in February 2017 Attorney
General jeff sessions began to assess
whether he had to recuse himself from
campaign related investigations because
of his role in the Trump campaign in
early March the president told the White
House Counsel Don McGann to stop
sessions from accusing after sessions
announced his refusal on March 2nd the
president expressed anger at the
decision and told advisers he should
have that he should have an attorney
general who had protect him the
president also took sessions aside at an
event and an urged him to Unruh cues
later in March James Comey disclosed at
a congressional hearing that the FBI was
investigating the Russian government's
efforts to interfere in the 2016
presidential election including any
links or coordination between the
Russian government and the Trump
campaign in the following days the
president reached out to the DNI
of national intelligence tan coats and
the leaders of the CIA and the National
Security Agency to ask them what they
could do to publicly dispel the
suggestion that the president had any
connections to the Russian election
interference effort the president also
called Co me twice directly
notwithstanding guidance from his own
White House Counsel Don Magan to avoid
direct contact with the Department of
Justice again does that constitute
obstruction of justice the answer is no
the President did not obstruct justice
by asking people to tell the truth which
is that he was not involved in Trump
Russia collusion and then the Mello
report discusses the termination of
combing and they say that within days of
Comey testifying in a congressional
hearing about whether the president was
personally under investigation the
president decided to terminate Comey the
president fired Comey and then he told
the Russian officials he had faced great
pressure because of Russia and that had
been taken off by commis firing but that
is not the same thing as the presidents
of the United States saying that he
fired Comey so Comey would not find
dirty material about Russia
he was just frustrated with Comey which
we already know cuz he said that on
national TV
the really dicey material for Trump is
all the stuff once we get to the
appointment of robert muller it seems
that once robert muller was actually
appointed then the president's attitude
became even more belligerent and his
activity included activity that looks
more akin to obstruction of justice than
his other activity now does it shade
over into a provable obstruction of
justice the answer is no but is it bad
immoral behavior yes and was he stopped
from doing stuff that certainly could
have been construed as obstruction of
justice by the people around him yeah he
definitely was it's not a great thing to
work for the president because if you
save him from himself he ends up hating
you for it but that is from this report
what probably happened here okay we'll
get to more of this in just a second
trying to be as objective about the
report as possible give you all the
information and then opinion but first
you need to go check out zip recruiter
so hiring is important and that's why is
appropriate calm slash daily wire is
your place to improve your business zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's at leading job boards we use
zip recruiter here at the daily wear
offices and makes our hiring fast and
simple they don't just stop with posting
your job with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in
super cooter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective at four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter can
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com slash daily wire that
is zip recruiter comm slash at Dai ly WI
re zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
it is indeed the smartest way to hire go
check out zip recruiter comm slash daily
wear try them out for free right now it
is the easiest and best way to improve
your business no need to put up that job
on a hundred job boards and then have to
sift through all those resumes zip
recruiter helps you out with all that
zip recruiter comm slash daily wired go
check them out right now zip recruiter
calm slash daily wire okay so in a
second we'll get back to the Muller
report first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wire comm and subscribe we
have so much great material for you two
additional hours of this show a day
maybe three today we have lots of stuff
there plus we've got the Sunday special
which you get on Saturdays this week's
Sunday special guest is the the
incomparable Dennis Miller who stopped
by for the full hour as Larry King used
to say here's a little bit of what that
sounded like I think they're a little
haunted by their good fortune so they're
trying to legitimize themselves now by
being you know professorial and I've got
some wisdom here and your things you're
the fifth lead on full house
[Laughter]
so go check that out you get that out in
Saturdays as opposed to as opposed to
Sundays when you are a subscriber also
so much good stuff
Andrew Cleveland's book another Kingdom
is out right now and receiving rave
reviews if you haven't picked up your
copy yet you can head on over to Amazon
or Barnes & Noble grab one while
supplies last and today only you can
catch drew doing the live book signing
on today's episode of the conversation
at 7:00 p.m. Eastern to get a signed
copy and a chance to have your question
answered head on over to premier
collectibles calm / another Kingdom that
is premiere with an e premier
collectibles calm / another Kingdom
TuneIn should be a blast
go check that out so much good stuff
also make sure you subscribe over at
iTunes and YouTube leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in America
[Music]
okay so at the point at which Comey was
fired and the Special Counsel
Robert Muller was appointed the
president's attitude turned and it got
even more angry and that anger
manifested itself in a bunch of
directives to his immediate aides to do
stuff that could theoretically be
construed as obstruction of justice if
they had actually carried it out and
would probably be prevented from an
obstruction of justice charge only
because the president's intent in saying
all this stuff was to prevent public
embarrassment not criminal indictment
that's why you hear bar keep coming back
to the point there was no collusion here
for the president to protect himself
against this was all him being
embarrassed by Press reports and so it
was him telling people hey maybe you
should just go out there and lie to the
press which by the way is also not
obstruction of justice lying to the
press is not obstruction of justice so
here's what the Moller report says they
say on May 17th 2017 the acting Attorney
General for the Russia investigation
appointed a special counsel to conduct
the investigation and related matters
the president reacted to that news by
telling advisors it was the
quote-unquote end of his presidency and
demanding the Jeff Sessions resigned
because he wanted to put in a new
Attorney General presumably who would
reign and Muller session submitted his
resignation the president ultimately did
not accept it the president told aides
that the special counsel had conflicts
of interest and suggested that the
special counsel therefore could not
serve the president advisers told him
the asserted conflicts were meritless
and had already beacons been considered
by the DOJ On June 17 2017 the president
called Don began his White House Counsel
and directed him to call the acting
Attorney General and say that the
special counsel had conflicts of
interest and must be removed McGann did
not carry out the direction however
deciding he would rather resign then
trigger what he regarded as a potential
Saturday night massacre
that's an invocation of the Nixon firing
of Attorney General Archibald Cox or the
special prosecutor Archibald Cox so you
know all of this is not necessarily
obstruction of justice but verges on it
from the point of view that says that
Trump was doing all of this stuff out of
frustration that people were going to
uncover his crimes again intent is an
element of the crime I keep coming back
to that because intent is an element of
the crime if this were a strict
liability crime Trump would be guilty
it is not a strict liability crime you
have to show that he had intent to
corruptly impede official proceedings
that is
proved here okay what are the other
efforts to curtail the special counsels
investigation
two days after directing began to have
the special counsel removed the
president made another attempt to affect
the course of the Russia investigation
On June 19 2017 the president met
one-on-one in the Oval Office with
former campaign manager and dope Corey
Lewandowski and dictated a message for
Lewandowski to deliver two sessions the
message said that sessions should
publicly announce notwithstanding his
refusal from the Russia investigation
that the investigation was very unfair
to the president that the president had
done nothing wrong and that sessions
planned to meet with the special counsel
and let him move forward with
investigating election meddling for
future elections Lewandowski said he
understood what the president wanted
sessions to do this is the thing that
comes closest to obstruction it is the
president trying to tell jeff sessions
that he was going to change the nature
of the special counsels purview now even
that is not necessarily obstruction in
the sense that the president does have
authority over the special counsel this
is the case that Alan Dershowitz has
made is that the special counsel does
work for the executive branch from can
fire him for whatever reason he wants
that's not obstruction that may be the
grounds for an impeachment but that is
not necessarily criminal obstruction one
month later in another private meeting
for Lewandowski on July 19th 2017 the
president asked about the status of his
message for sessions to limit the
Special Counsel investigation to future
election interference
Lewandowski told the president the
message would be delivered soon after
that meeting the president publicly
criticized sessions in an interview with
the New York Times and then issued a
series of tweets making it clear that
sessions his job was in jeopardy
Lewandowski did not want to deliver the
president's message message personally
so he asked senior White House official
Rick Dearborn to deliver it to sessions
Durbin was uncomfortable at the task and
did not end up following through
sessions never received this message his
adviser advisors prevented what could
have been construed as obstruction of
justice right there and then there are a
bunch of accusations that the president
made efforts to prevent public
disclosure of evidence but public
disclosure of evidence is not in fact a
criminal offense and if I tell somebody
to lied to the press that is not
criminal and may be bad but Trump lies
to the press all the time so again baked
into the cake so when the muddler
investigation says that in summer 2017
the president instructed Donald Trump
jr. to delete a line from his statement
about the Trump Tower meeting to the
press
that is not actually obstruction of
justice that's just him being bad and
when Michael Cohen repeatedly denied
that the president had played any role
in Trump jr. statement that was lying to
the public that's bad that is not
criminal hey finally the Muller
investigation says in early summer 2017
the president called sessions at home
and again asked him to reverse his
recusal from the Russia investigation
sessions did not reverse his refusal on
October 2017 the president met privately
with sessions in the Oval Office and
asked him to take a look at
investigating Clinton in December 2017
shortly after Flynn pled guilty pursuant
to a cooperation agreement the president
met with sessions in the Oval Office and
suggested according to notes taken by a
senior advisor that if sessions Unruh
cused and took back supervision of the
Russia investigation he would be a hero
sessions of course did not unruhe cues
and the Muller investigation went
forward as as stated so as we say the
question as to whether the president did
stuff that was quote-unquote criminal
here is not provable it's not a provable
question which is probably the reason
that Muller left it up in the air and I
think Attorney General Barr looked at
this and said there's no way that I can
prove this beyond a reasonable doubt him
going to various advisors and fuming
about Jeff Sessions and then not doing
anything especially when he has the full
authority to just fire whomever he wants
he wants to fire jeff Sessions he can
fire jeff Sessions if he wants to fire
Robert Muller he can fire Robert Muller
if he wants to order an invent when
invest in end to an investigation the
president can even do that right he can
even order the end to an investigation
without that necessarily being criminal
obstruction of justice since he has in
fact the President of the United States
that may be impeachable it is not
necessarily criminal in a second we'll
get to more on the Muller report so the
Mullen report continues by talking about
whether the president ordered people to
lie so apparently in early 2018 the
Press reported that President Trump had
directed John McGann to have the special
counsel removed in June 2017 and that
McGann had threatened to resign rather
than carry out the order the president
reacted to the news stories by directing
White House officials to tell McGann to
dispute the story and create a record
stating that he had not been ordered to
have the special counsel removed McGann
told those officials that the media
reports were accurate in stating that
the President had directed McGann
to have the special counsel removed so
again this is the president telling his
to tell Magan to publicly dispute the
story that is not necessarily the
president telling people to lie to legal
investigators now if you want to broadly
read the statute and a lot of this
relies on sort of legalese if you want
to broadly read the statute to suggest
that the president was corruptly in
tensing to interfere with a pending
investigation by publicly tweeting
things I don't think that that actually
works legally speaking if the president
tweets something publicly he says like I
hate robert mower and then the charge is
you tried to corrupt lee impede the
investigation that doesn't work and if
he told Don McGann go out and lie to the
press that is also a terrible thing to
do it is not a criminal thing to do the
same thing holds true with regard to
Mike Flynn and Paul Mann afford the
suggestion that the president was
publicly going around saying about Flynn
and manna fort and Michael Cohen where
he was praising them and then he was
criticizing them based on whether they
were talking to the government he was
doing all of that in public right he was
calling Michael Cohen a rat is that
obstruction of justice I mean probably
not given that the president can sound
off on his opinion as much as he wants
he could run into serious First
Amendment issues if he called it
obstruction of justice for the president
to issue his opinion that Michael Cohen
was a rat so here's what the Mullen
report says they say although the series
of events we investigated involved
discrete acts the overall pattern of the
president's conduct toward the
investigations can shed light on the
nature of the president's acts and the
inferences that can be drawn about his
intent in particular the actions we
investigated can be divided into two
phases reflecting a possible shift in
the president's motives
the first phase covered the period from
the president's first interactions with
Comey through the president's firing of
Comey
during that time the president had been
repeatedly told he was not personally
under investigation
soon after the firing of Comey and the
reappoint and the appointment of the
special counsel however the president
became aware that his own conduct was
being investigated in an obstruction of
justice inquiry at that point the
president engaged in a second phase of
conduct involving public attacks on the
investigations non-public efforts to
control it and efforts in both public
and private to encourage witnesses not
to cooperate with the investigation now
here's the thing you would think that
that sentence alone under the under the
broadest standard of obstruction would
fall under obstruction right I mean they
are accusing him point-blank of non
public efforts to control the nature of
the investigation but that doesn't again
actually mean obscure
of Justice unless he is doing so with
corrupt intent and that's Trump's best
argument I'm angry I'm mad that this
investigation was going forward I'm
pissed off in general and so I was
sounding off to my people saying you
know what let's shut this thing down cuz
I'm angry that I'm not being exonerated
just exonerate me already what the hell
is this stuff that is Trump's best
offense it always was Trump's best
defense judgments about the nature of
the president's motives during each
phase would be informed by the totality
of the evidence now what that sentence
is basically saying is that Muller
suspects that Trump actually wanted to
shut down the investigation but there's
not enough evidence to prove that the
president wanted to shut down the
investigation for corrupt purposes they
said because we ultimately determined
not to make a traditional prosecutorial
judgement we did not draw conclusions
about the president's conduct the
evidence we obtained about the
president's actions and intent intent
presents difficult issues that would
need to be resolved if we were making a
traditional prosecutorial judgment at
the same time if we had confidence after
a thorough investigation of the facts
that the president clearly did not
commit obstruction of justice we would
so state based on the facts and the
applicable legal standards we are unable
to reach that judgment accordingly while
this report does not conclude that the
president committed a crime it also does
not exonerate him and bottom line is
this is all about intent how do you read
the president's intent so people who
don't like the president are gonna read
it and so the president's intent was to
quash the investigation out of guilt
again there's no underlying crime and
people who are more fond of the
President and frankly people I think
we're more objective look at this and
they say there was no underlying crime
the president is a temperamental person
at best the president says a lot of dumb
crap to his advisers those advisers shut
him down on a regular basis and stopped
him from doing things that would border
on the criminal or veer into the
criminal and thus while he has done bad
immoral things here while he has exerted
pressure in certain areas that does not
amount to obstruction of justice with
corrupt intent and that seems to be the
nature of a lot of this stuff so for
example so for example when the
president was upset about Mike Flynn's
firing he had lunch with Chris Christie
according to Christie at one point
during the lunch Trump said now that we
fired Flynn the Russian thing is over
and Christie laughed and responded no
way the president asked Christie what he
meant
and the president Christie told the
president not to talk about the
investigation even if he was frustrated
at times toward the end of the lunch the
president brought up James Comey who's
an FBI director asked if Christie was
still friendly with him Christie said he
was the president told Christie to call
Comey and tell him that the president
really likes him tell him he's part of
the team at the end of the lunch the
president repeated his request that
Christie reach out to economy
Christie had no intention of complying
with the president's request that he
contact call me he thought the
president's request was nonsensical
Christie did not want to put Comey in a
position of having to receive such a
phone call
hey so again this is Trump lashing out
being mad at the investigation saying
why don't you call up Jim's coming and
say they were best friends and chris
christie going on it's dumb and that's
the end of it is that obstruction i
don't think that amounts to obstruction
and most of the cases in here are just
like that
most of the cases in here are very much
akin to something like that again when
it comes to Jeff Sessions and March 3rd
the day after sessions recused time
again was called into the Oval Office
other advisers were there including
Priebus and Ryan's previous than the
chief of staff and Steve Ben and the
president opened the conversation by
saying I don't have a lawyer he
expressed anger and magan about the
recusal he brought up Roy Cohn saying he
wished Cohen was his attorney he
suggested that Jenna that Attorney
General Robert Kennedy and Eric Holder
would not have allowed this sort of
thing and then he pushed back on policy
suggesting he should not make that he
should not make contact with Jeff
Sessions or with anyone else in the DOJ
that weekend sessions and began flew
Tamara Lago to meet with the president
sessions recalled the president pulled
him aside to speak to him alone
suggested that sessions should Unruh
cues from the Russia investigation which
he did not do and Trump did not fire him
so again is that obstruction of justice
or is that trumps just being a dummy so
much of this falls under Trump was
frustrated and I think justifiably
frustrated about the nature of the
investigation the intrusiveness of the
investigation does this count as
obstructive activity it's sort of a
matter of art rather than law but is it
provable obstruction I think under no
circumstances could you call this stuff
provable obstruction okay time for a
quick thing that I like and then a thing
that I hate so things that I like now I
like to recall times in American
politics that were a little bit higher
minded when people had discussions about
ideas well if you're interested in that
sort of stuff go pick up a copy of the
lincoln-douglas debates the best version
of this comes from Lincoln studies
Center is edited
by Rodney Davis and Douglas Wilson it's
a revision of the original text because
there are several original text they
sort of compiled what they think is the
best version and it really does raise
issues not only about the nature of the
American Constitution and founding
principles Douglas basically claimed
that slavery was at least protected by
the Constitution Lincoln said that the
Constitution in the Declaration
installed immutable principles that cut
against slavery itself and thus you
could not create laws that would
effectuate the addition of slavery to
additional territories it has stuff to
say about the nature of the American
Founding about the nature of America
when we were getting rid of slavery
about the nature of questions like
abortion where people very often take
the Stephen Douglas position I'll just
leave it to each individual state the
Lincoln position would be protection of
human life is a is a universal absolute
and there's just a lot there and it's
deep and it's meaty and it's it's great
reading go check out the lincoln-douglas
debates totally worthwhile ok time for a
couple of things that I hate ok so the
big thing that I hate today we'll stick
to one thing that I hate today so
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez has put out in
astonishing video I didn't know whether
to put this in things I like or things
that I hate because there it's just
amazing so she put out a video that was
supposed to be her new take on the green
New Deal
suffice it to say this video is the most
arrogant thing that has ever been
produced on the internet it is AOC
speaking about how she saved the world
no joke about how she in the future is
gonna talk to us now she this is video
from AOC in the future talking about how
she and her friends saved the world
thanks to the green New Deal it's pretty
incredible we'll play a little bit of it
ah the bullet train from New York to
DC's it always brings me back to when I
first started making this commute in
2019 I was a freshman in the most
diverse Congress in history up to that
point it was a critical time I'll never
forget the children in our community
they were so inspired to see this new
class of politicians they were so
inspired by me guys so SuperDuper
inspired me you can't be what you can't
see and for the first time they saw
themselves wow I think there was
something similar with the green New
Deal we knew that we needed to save the
planet and that we had all the
technology to do it so the people were
scared they said it was too big too fast
not practical I think that's because
they just couldn't picture it yeah they
couldn't see getting ahead of myself
then a suit came along god she's amazing
and then we fast forward to the end okay
and and she actually makes the case that
the green New Deal saved the world that
had created magical new jobs that the
biggest problem after creating Medicare
for all
she says this in the video Medicare for
all and a Federal jobs guarantee the
biggest problem is we couldn't find
enough workers we needed more workers
there was too much prosperity things
were too awesome thanks to AOC and her
band of friends and this is her in the
future talking about the present so she
has created a fictional future in which
she was awesome and saved the world
I am so convinced a public option
including dignified living wages for
works
funnily enough the biggest problem in
those early years was a labor shortage
we're building a national smart grid
retrofitting every building in America
putting trains like this one all across
the country we needed more workers that
group of kids from my neighborhood were
right in the middle of it all especially
this one girl it's so absurd it's so she
was with AmeriCorps climate restoring
wetlands and bayous in coastal Louisiana
most of her friends were in her Union
including some oil workers entrants all
the oil workers are now restoring by
these guys exciting stuff King mangroves
with the same salary and benefits oh man
of course when it came to
sealing the land we had huge gaps in our
knowledge
luckily indigenous communities offered
generational expertise I love this just
random random Native Americans show up
to explain how to fix the bayous and
then by the way this girl goes on from
working in the bayous to working in a
solar plant and then she decides she
wants to be a preschool teacher making
150 grand a year in a OCS magical it
must be nice to be in a Aussies brain
really like it must be a nice happy
place like there's not a lot going on in
there it seems pretty calm it seems like
things are she has a really like
optimistic vision of what the future is
going to be if you just give her
complete and utter control over the
entire United States economy must be a
wonderful place in there so go check out
that video because it is beyond parody
okay other things that I hate today so
for the second time in two days the
Washington Post has suggested that I am
a white supremacist damn it guys why
don't you read a book a book okay a
column I wrote a piece for the
Washington Post in 2015
talking about how evil white supremacism
is what the hell are you talking about
there's a piece in The Washington Post
today remember just two days ago they
printed a piece in which they suggested
that I had vote the specter of a war
between Islam and the West by saying
that notre-dame Cathedral was an homage
to Western civilization and
judeo-christian heritage well today they
published another piece saying quote ben
shapiro an influential american
right-wing pundit with a huge following
on social media lamented a magnificent
monument to Western civilization
collapsing and then followed up with
tweets that insisted upon the
judeo-christian heritage embodied by no
tree Dom and a duty of all to reef
amilia rise ourselves with the
philosophy and religious principles that
built it
critics quickly noted the brutal
treatment meted out on French Jews for
centuries while the cathedral stood
you're right guys I totally missed it I
totally missed you know how Christian
anti-semitism has been a thing you know
as an Orthodox Jew I can't no
familiarity with it Wow breaking news
others suggested I love this is the
Washington Post reporting others
suggested shapira's invocation of
judeo-christian values were in this
instance simply a euphemism for white fu
man I wrote an entire book devoted to
why that is a stupid idiotic notion and
then they go further they say Richard
Spencer an American neo-fascist credited
with coining the term alt-right for the
online ecosystem of far-right voices in
the West spoke more plainly I you see I
am covert where Richard Spencer
overt again double down on the fu that
is astonishing astonishing language from
the Washington Post my book is entirely
about the judeo-christian heritage and
Greek teleology that undergird the West
I have suggested throughout my entire
career that Western civilization is not
unique to any particular race and to
construe it that way
is to reduce Western civilization to
mere tribalism which is idiocy in my
book I specifically mention Richard
Spencer I call him a racist on
page 22 of the introduction and
execrable on page 208 and apparently I'm
just secret I'm just secret all right
I'm just a secret white supremacist what
absolute hackish garbage Washington Post
democracy dies in darkness the truth
dies and stupidity over at the
Washington Post okay well we will be
back here a little bit later for much
much more breakdown on the Muller report
and the fallout join us then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua ov era
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show Attorney General William Bar
has released the Mulla report with
relatively few redactions he gives a
highly entertaining press conference on
the details of its release we will
analyze all the relevant sections the
good the bad and the ugly check it out
of daily wire calm